[Musique]
mais j'aime luchon d'un beau
saint-maurice paris tout simplement la
neige un complice miracle de transformer
en station de sports d'hiver les jardins
du trocadéro et parisiens et parisiennes
que retient ici le malheur des portes au
plus pour deux jours chausser les skis
et réinventer descente et slalom à
l'ombre de la tour eiffel
[Musique]
il faut dire que depuis vingt ans paris
n'avait connu pareille chute de neige
trente centimètres en deux jours disait
satisfait
[Musique]
et les plus jeunes les allemands qui
occupaient paris n'a guère ont dû
s'occuper de paris
[Musique]
pourquoi chercher si loin les joies qui
vous attendent devant votre porte pense
maurice baquet île maurice paquet
reprend aujourd'hui un entraînement qui
le mènera loin sur des pentes depuis
longtemps s'élève celle de mon âme
[Musique]